hello everyone it's a bit funny because
I did write that humans will become
digital but I didn't think it will
happen so fast and that it will happen
to me
but here I am as a digital avatar and
here you are so let's start and let's
start with a question how many fascists
are there in the audience today well
it's a bit difficult the same because
we've forgotten what fascism is people
now use the term fascist as a kind of
general purpose abuse or they confuse
fascism with nationalism so let's take a
few minutes to clarify what fascism
actually is and how is it different from
nationalism the amount of forms of
nationalism have been among the most
benevolent of human creations nations
are communities of millions of strangers
who don't really know each other for
example I don't know the 8 million
people who share my Israeli citizenship
but thanks to nationalism we can all
care about one another and cooperate
effectively this is very good
some people like John Lennon imagine
that without nationalism the world will
be a peaceful paradise but far more
likely without nationalism we would have
been living in tribal chaos if you look
today at the most prosperous and
peaceful countries in the world
countries like Sweden and Switzerland
and Japan you will see that they have a
very strong sense of nationalism in
contrast countries that lack a strong
sense of nationalism like Congo and
Somalia and Afghanistan tend to be
violent and poor so what is fascism and
how is it different from now
journalism well nationalism tells me
that my nation is unique and that I have
special obligations towards my nation
fascism in contrast tells me that not my
nation is supreme and that I have
exclusive obligations towards it I don't
need to care about anybody or anything
other than my nation usually of course
people have many identities and
loyalties to different groups for
example I can be a good Patriot loyal to
my country and at the same time be loyal
to my family my neighborhood my
profession humankind as a whole truth
and beauty of course when I have
different identities and loyalties it
sometimes creates conflicts and
complications but well whoever told you
that life was easy life is complicated
deal with it
fascism is what happens when people try
to ignore the complications and to make
life too easy for themselves
fascism denies all identities except the
national identity and insists that I
have obligations only towards my nation
if my nation demands that I sacrificed
my family then I will sacrifice my
family if the nation demands that I kill
millions of people then I will kill
millions of people and if my nation
demands that i betray truth and beauty
then i should betray truth and beauty
for example how does the fascist
evaluate art how does a fascist decides
whether a movie is a good movie or a bad
movie well it's very very very simple so
it's really just one yardstick if the
movie serves the interests of the nation
it's a good movie
if the movie doesn't serve the interest
of the nation it's a bad movie that's it
similarly how does the fascists decide
what to teach kids in school again it is
very simple there is just one yardstick
you teach the kids whatever serves the
interests of the nation the truth
doesn't matter at all
now the horrors of the Second World War
and of the Holocaust remind us of the
terrible consequences of this way of
thinking but usually when we talk about
the ills of fascism we do so in an
ineffective way because we tend to
depict fascism as a hideous monster
without really explaining what was so
seductive about it it's a bit like these
Hollywood movies that depict the bad
guys Voldemort or Lord Sauron or Darth
Vader is ugly and mean and cruel they're
cruel even to their own supporters when
I see these movies I never understand
why would anybody be tempted to follow a
disgusting creep like Voldemort the
problem with evil is that in real life
evil doesn't necessarily look ugly it
can look very beautiful this is
something that Christianity knew very
well which is why in Christian art as
against Hollywood Satan is usually
depicted as a gorgeous hunk this is why
it's so difficult to resist the
temptations of Satan and why it is also
difficult to resist the temptations of
fascism fascism makes people see
themselves as belonging to the most
beautiful and most important thing in
the world the nation and then people
think well they taught us that fascism
is ugly but when I look in the mirror I
see something very beautiful so I can't
be a fascist right wrong that's the
problem with fascism when you look in
the fascist
you see yourself as far more beautiful
than you really are in the 1930s when
Germans looked in the fascist mirror
they saw Germany is the most beautiful
thing in the world if today Russians
look in the fascist mirror they will see
Russia is the most beautiful thing in
the world and if Israelis look in the
fascist mirror they will see Israel as
the most beautiful thing in the world
this does not mean that we are now
facing a rerun of the 1930s fascism and
dictatorships might come back but they
will come back in a new form a form
which is much more relevant to the new
technological realities of the 21st
century in ancient times
land was the most important asset in the
world politics therefore was the
struggle to control land and
dictatorship meant that all the land was
owned by a single ruler or by a small
oligarchy then in the modern age
machines became more important than land
politics became the struggle to control
the machines and dictatorship meant the
- many of the machines became
concentrated in the hands of the
government of a small elite now data is
replacing both land and machines as the
most important asset politics becomes
the struggle to control the flows of
data and dictatorship now means that too
much data is being concentrated in the
hands of the government or of a small
elite the greatest danger that now faces
liberal democracy is that the revolution
in information technology will make
dictatorships more efficient than
democracies in the 20th century
democracy and capitalism defeated
fascism in communion
because democracy was better at
processing data and making decisions
given 20th century technology
it was simply inefficient to try and
concentrate too much data and too much
power in one place but it is not a law
of nature that centralized data
processing is always less efficient than
distributed data processing with the
rise of artificial intelligence and
machine learning it might become
feasible to process enormous amounts of
information very efficiently in one
place to take all the decisions in one
place and then centralized data
processing will be more efficient than
distributed data processing and then the
main handicap of authoritarian regimes
in the 20th century their attempt to
concentrate all the information in one
place it will become their greatest
advantage another technological danger
that threatens the future of democracy
is the merger of information technology
with biotechnology which might result in
the creation of algorithms that no mean
better than I know myself
and once you have such algorithms an
external system like the government
cannot just predict my decisions it can
also manipulate my feelings my emotions
a dictator may not be able to provide me
with good healthcare but he will be able
to make me love him and to make me hate
the opposition democracy will find it
difficult to survive such a development
because in the end democracy is not
based on human rationality it's based on
human feelings during elections and
referendums you're not being asked
what do you think you're actually being
asked how do you feel and if somebody
can manipulate your emotions effectively
democracy will become an emotional
puppet show so what can we do to prevent
the return of fascism and the rise of
new dictatorships the number one
question that we face is who controls
the data if you are an engineer then
find ways to prevent too much data from
being concentrated in too few hands and
find ways to make sure the distributed
data processing is at least as efficient
as centralized data processing this will
be the best safeguard for democracy as
for the rest of us who are not engineers
the number one question facing us is how
not to allow ourselves to be manipulated
by those who control the data the
enemies of liberal democracy they have a
method they hack our feelings not our
emails not our bank accounts they hack
our feelings of fear and hate and vanity
and then use these feelings to polarize
and destroy democracy from within this
is actually a method that Silicon Valley
pioneered in order to sell us products
but now the enemies of democracy are
using this very method to sell us fear
and hate and vanity they cannot create
these feelings out of nothing so they
get to know our own pre-existing
weaknesses and then use them against us
and it is therefore the responsibility
of all of us to get to know our
weaknesses and make sure that they do
not become a weapon in the hands of the
enemies of democracy
getting to know our own weaknesses will
also help us to avoid the trap of the
fascist mirror as we explained earlier
fascism exploits our vanity it makes us
see ourselves is far more beautiful than
we really are
this is the seduction but if you really
know yourself you will not fall for this
kind of flattery if somebody puts a
mirror in front of your eyes that hides
all your ugly bits and makes you see
yourself is far more beautiful and far
more important than you really are just
break that mirror thank you
Deebo thank you goodness me and it's
it's so nice to see you again you know
so if I understand you right you're
alerting us to two big dangers here one
is the possible resurgence of a
seductive form of fascism but close to
that dictatorships that may not exactly
be fascistic but but control or the data
and wonder if there's there's a third
concern that some people have already
expressed which is we're not governments
but big corporations control all our
data what do you call that and how
worried should we be about that well in
the end there isn't such a big
difference between the corporations and
the governments because as I said the
question is who controls the data this
is the real government if you call it a
corporation or a government if it's a
corporation and it really controls the
data this is our real government so is
that the difference is more apparent
than real right I somehow at least with
corporations you can imagine market
mechanisms where they can be taken down
I mean if consumers just decided the
company is no longer operating in their
interest it does open the door to
another market it seems is it to imagine
that then say you know citizens rising
up and taking down a government that is
in control of everything but we are not
there yet
but again if a corporation really knows
you better than you know yourself then
as I said it can manipulate your own
deepest emotions and desires and you
won't even realize you will think this
is your authentic self so in theory yes
in fear you can rise against the
corporation just as in theory you can
rise against the dictatorship but in
practice it is extremely difficult
so in houma days you argued that this
would be the century when humans kind of
became gods either through development
of artificial intelligence or through
genetic engineering has this prospect of
political system shift collapse impacted
your view on that possibility well I
think it makes it even more likely and
and more likely that it will happen fast
because in times of crisis people are
willing to take risks that they wouldn't
otherwise take and people are willing to
try all kinds of high risk high high
gain technologies so these kinds of
crisis might serve the same function as
the two world wars in the 20th century
the two world wars greatly accelerated
the development of new and dangerous
technologies and the same thing might
happen in the 21st century I mean you
need to be a little crazy to run too
fast let's say with little engineering
but now you have more and more crazy
people in charge of different countries
in the world so the chances are getting
higher not lower
it's a bring or together you've uh
you've got this unique vision like roll
the clock for 30 years what's your guest
is humanity somehow just scraped through
look back and say wow that was the
clothes thing we did it or not
well so far we've managed to overcome
all the previous crisis and especially
if you look about at liberal democracy
and you think things out our bed now
just remember how much worse things
looked in 1938 or in 1968 so this is
really nothing this is just a small
crisis but you can never know because as
a historian I know that you should never
underestimate human stupidity this is
one of the most powerful forces but
shape history you've always been an
absolute delight to have you with us
thank you for making the virtual trip
have a great evening there are gonna be
devar Ari thank you thank you very much
[Music]